[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue sur le plateau de ce sens
public on est ensemble pour 90 minutes
une heure trente de débat de reportages
et des expertises la promesse vous savez
elle est dans le titre donner du sens à
l'actualité et se mettre au service du
public vous proposer des clés de
compréhension des mutations profondes de
notre société voici le sommaire de ce 15
septembre emmanuel macron va-t-il
accélérer sur la réforme des retraites
le président pourrait l'intégrer à
l'examen du budget les syndicats et les
oppositions sont déjà vent debout
dénoncent un passage en force voici la
réponse du porte-parole du gouvernement
ne serait pas de passage en force ça
s'appelle un débat au parlement
les retraites mais aussi la rentrée
parlementaire du parti et l'air et puis
la gauche qui se bagarrent sur la valeur
travail trois thèmes pour notre premier
débat 100% politique
et puis dans 45 minutes ne ratez pas
l'analyse de l'eau experts sur la
banalisation de l'extrême droite en
europe la suède et l'italie sont en
train de basculer des victoires
électorales qui repose notamment mais
pas seulement sur le thème de
l'immigration et qui fragilise certaines
des valeurs fondatrices de l'union
européenne vous verrez mais d'abord la
réforme des retraites et cette tentation
du sprint cécile siksou emmanuel macron
est pressé il veut faire démarrer sa
réforme des retraites avant l'été 2023
et pour accélérer le tempo l'hypothèse
de l'intégrer sous forme d'amendements
dans le projet de loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale fait son chemin le
gouvernement en tout cas ne l'exclût pas
dans ce qu'on souhaite c'est que ça
démarre à l'été 2003 il ya plusieurs
moyens d'y parvenir dont celui que vous
avez évoquées mais des discussions sont
en cours il n'y a pas de décision prise
sur le sujet les élections aucune
hypothèse la première ministre l'a dit
hier nous devons trouver ses modalités
ne sont pas arrêtés mais tant qu'elles
ne sont pas arrêtés nous n'excluons
aucune hypothèse qu il est urgent de
faire une réforme et de l'enclencher on
parle on parle il faut agir
côté lr6 députés et sénateurs réunis à
biarritz pour leurs journées
parlementaires ne sont pas contre une
réforme des retraites il ne cautionne
pas la méthode ya plein de sujets qui
méritent quand même un minimum de
discussions avec les partenaires sociaux
donc je ne peux pas passer une situation
on a eu monsieur delevoye qui a
travaillé trois ans pour rien à une
situation où on règlerait ça en trois
jours donc voilà c'est peut-être le
parlement contre les partenaires sociaux
il faut qu'il ya un minimum de
concertation avant d'arriver devant le
parlement à gauche même constat passer
au dessus des discussions serait un
manque de respect pour les partenaires
sociaux si si le président de la
république fait ça c'est une provocation
parce que faire passer ça dans le projet
de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale c'est effectivement très simple
ça peut prendre cinq minutes voilà c'est
une ligne qu'on rajoute c'est un débat
entre droite et gauche on sait comment
il sera soldé donc ça veut dire qu' il
n'y a pas eu de négociations avant si le
gouvernement choisit cette option il
devra en tout cas faire face à une
opposition claire du rn6 emmanuel macron
comme je peux l'entendre se sert du
budget de la sécurité sociale pour
s'attaquer aux retraites c'est-à-dire
contourner en réalité un débat
véritablement sur ce sujet il va se
trouver confronté à une opposition
totale de notre part face à l'opposition
de la plupart des partis le gouvernement
pourrait utiliser l'article 49 3 de la
constitution qui lui permet de faire
passer la loi sans vote du parlement
un passage en force qui pourrait braquer
l'opinion et faire descendre dans la rue
les opposants au projet de réforme la
réforme des retraites ces thèmes le
premier thème de ce débat avec nathalie
morel bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste politique pour le groupe
ebra jacques également mathieu souquet
jesenice bonsoir bien mathieu bienvenue
à jean sébastien ferjou bonsoir
fondateur-directeur d'atlantico et
lætitia cru pas il tord à disposition à
mes côtés comme chaque jeudi la
tentation du sprint c'est bien ce que
j'ai prononcé est pas une référence à
une boisson qu'on a peut-être tous goûté
pendant l'été vous êtes un peu en
vacances les uns et les autres à avoir
entendu sept cette concession bref ce
n'est pas très grave
nathalie morin cette tentation
d'accélérer je veux dire ça comme ça le
calendrier sur la réforme des retraites
pourquoi emmanuel macron at-il cette
tentation est ce qu'il imagine peut-être
une faible mobilisation de l'opinion ça
pouvait part de son analyse je pense que
si on partie sale bord pour refaire le
film quand il voit les journalistes de
l'association de la presse
présidentielle donc c'était lundi moi j
étais je peux vous assurer qu'on était
environ 80 90 on a tous étaient saisis
canton quand le président de la
république nous a dit que oui c'est très
cette réforme était absolument utile et
qu'il fallait aller très vite quand on
lui a demandé si c'était possible de le
faire dans le cadre du plfss il n'a pas
dit oui
je sais ça pourquoi il fait ça pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est
parce qu'il a le sentiment est sans
doute à juste titre que l'opinion est
plus dans la lassitude que dans la
colère on sort de deux années
de pandémie on est actuellement
complètement dans l'inquiétude par
rapport à
à l'inflation et au coût de la vie il
sait que les français même s'ils sont un
peu agacé son ont quand même conscience
qu'en france est plutôt mieux
qu'ailleurs
donc il se dit voilà c'est un sujet
épineux c'est un sujet qui de toute
façon ne fera pas l'unanimité donc si je
le fais maintenant
peut-être qu'à une façon peut-être que
ça se passera mieux le plus tard le
deuxième calcule qu'il fait c'est que
lui il en tirera un bénéfice il
apparaîtra comme un réformateur alors
que pour l'instant il n'apparaît pas
comme un réformateur or c'était son adn
c'est pour ça qu'il avait été élu en
2010 est donc il apparaîtra comme un
référendum comme un réformateur pardon
et ça viendra mettre un coin sur sa
droite ou à l'opposition et l'air
l'opposition et l'eire qui lui
reprochent justement de ne pas avoir
fait cette réforme matthieu suc souvient
ou quoi bonne idée ou erreur politique
s'il le fait en tout cas c'est un risque
politique mais je revendique totalement
et je souscris à ce que vous dites il ya
effectivement l'adn réformateur
d'emmanuel macron avec lequel il a sans
doute envie de renouer il ya peut-être
la volonté aussi de redevenir un peu le
maître des horloges ça fait des semaines
et des mois qu'il a perdu la main sur
l'agenda politique et son que c'est une
façon de prendre un peu tout le monde de
court et par surprise est effectivement
sans doute at il eu la grande enquête
que vos confrères de challenge ont
publié d'instituer harris interactive il
ya quinze jours dans le challenge avec
justement un long papier d'emmanuel
macron pour commenter l'humeur des
français l'état d'esprit des français
pour présenter un peu sa feuille de
route de la rentrée et cette enquête est
assez saisissante parce que alors que
les français sont ultra pessimiste est
depuis longtemps plus pessimiste que
tous les autres peuples on voit que
l'opinion française en cette rentrée
semble se porter moins mal que lors des
rentrées précédentes mieux même les deux
sentiers les deux sentiments qui
dominent sont positifs ça n'est jamais
le cas quand on prend le pouls des
français se sont toujours l'inquiétude
la lassitude et la peur qui domine là
c'est la détermination et une forme
d'optimisme donc peut-être que emmanuel
macron a pris très au sérieux cette
enquête et qu'il se dit que il y a
effectivement un trou de souris mais
pourtant il ya un risque politique très
net sur le fond encore une fois ça
n'était pas la priorité politique ça ne
figurait pas parmi les priorités
politiques qui l'avaient assigné à
isabelle borne au moment de sa
nomination il avait dit un planification
écologique de santé trois écoles ils
avaient plus parler de la réforme des
retraites il n'apparaît qu'à tous ceux
qui pensaient que c'était surprenant
et sur la forme quand même il ya une
vraie prise de risque il nous a expliqué
que le deuxième quinquennat allait se
dérouler de façon radicalement
différente que la méthode ne serait pas
du tout la même que le parlement
lui-même aurait et à dialoguer à
débattre et à et à nouer des compromis
là on fait l'inversé et j'ajoute même
que il abat y passer toute la société
civile et tous les corps intermédiaires
pendant les cinq années écoulées et là
et le medef fia et leurs prêts les
représentants des patrons du patronat
est le premier syndicat français la cfdt
ont dit que la réforme des retraites des
retraites ne devait pas nous être
inscrite à l'agenda de la rentrée
justement jean sébastien ferjou c'était
là dessus vous les entendre peut-être
sur la la la gouvernance ou la
conception du pouvoir des manuels macron
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière cette
possible décision d'accélérer sur les
retraites est passé comme ça via le ring
du budget sur ses motivations à lui
probablement effectivement ce qui a été
exposé là en revanche à mon sens c'est
non seulement un risque politique parce
que quel que soit l'humeur des français
on peut facilement imaginer que des
oppositions serait capable de mettre les
gens dans la rue et puisque c'est un
calcul essentiellement budgétaire qui
est fait sur la réforme des retraites ya
pas dans l'absolu une urgence tout de
suite le système est à l' équilibre là
en l'état il ne le sera pas sur ce
projet d'entente mais là en l'état sur
les années qui viennent il l'est c'est
un arbitrage budgétaire qu'il veut faire
mais ça c'est un déni démocrate afin pas
de faire un arbitrage budgétaire mais de
passer par cette voie là parce que pour
le coup olivier ferrand est
particulièrement hypocrite en disant
qu'il ya un débat c'est un débat mais
que de toute façon le gouvernement le
fait voter par le 49-3 peu importe qui
aura est ce qui aurait été dit dans le
débat mais je pense quand même qu'on
prend un grand risque politique il faut
se souvenir vous faisait référence à
l'état des français où l'opinion des
français mais les français il disait
aussi très largement qu'ils étaient en
faveur de la transition énergétique et
de la taxe carbone avant les gilet jaune
et puis il ya eu les gillet avons-nous
fait c'est pour ça je vous disais même
en matière d'arbitrage budgétaire
avons-nous fait le calcul de ce qu'a
coûté à la france de ce qu'ont coûté à
la france les mouvements sociaux du
quinquennat précédent lequel le pays a
été bloquée je vous parle pas du coc
vide emmanuel macron n'est évidemment
pas responsable du coc vide il est en
revanche assez largement sur les gilet
jaune et il l'était aussi sur la réforme
des retraites combien de commerces ont
dû fermer à cause de ça parce que quand
vous commencez à rentrer dans des
logiques budgétaire parce que pourquoi
on veut faire cette réforme des
retraites quand je vous disais c'est pas
pour les clips des retraites en soit
c'est pour dégager des marges de
manoeuvre budgétaires pour le reste mais
ça ça mérite c'est un vrai enjeu mais ça
mérite un véritable débat démocratique
pas de passer comme ça parce que l'état
peut faire beaucoup de il ya beaucoup il
suffit de lire les rapports de la cour
des comptes a sion le faire des
économies à beaucoup d'endroits on veut
les faire pourquoi les français
devrait-il être la variable d'ajustement
pour qu'elle mène ma qu'on puisse
montrer le vrai à son image je suis un
réformateur et par ailleurs pour que
l'état ne fasse lui aucun effort sur ces
films là tout vous avez thomas une drôle
de conception du spring parce que quand
même cette réforme des retraites il l'a
annoncé en 2010 est passé en force c'est
une erreur de pure stratégie politique
pourquoi passer en force ce qu'on
annonce depuis plus de cinq ans c'est
difficilement compréhensible
il l'a annoncé il faut leur dos et il
faut l'assumer il faut avoir le courage
politique et la volonté de l'expliquer
aux français peut-être comme dit jean
sébastien parce que nous avons besoin
effectivement de dégager davantage de
budget mais je ne comprends pas cette ce
passage à force il ya une explication
peut-être mathieu soutien vous pouvez
rappeler l'usagé du 49-3 sais c'est pas
s'il n'y a pas beaucoup de cartouches
dans le barillet quoi il y en a une pour
le budget de toute façon et puis on peut
y en avoir une autre pour un autre
une autre réforme donc là c'est une
façon de sauvegarder une cartouche pour
la réforme institutionnelle
effectivement de 2008-2009 change la
donne non seulement emmanuel macron ne
pourra pas se représenter mais d'ici la
fin de 5 de son quinquennat il ne pourra
faire qu'un usage limité du 49-3 comme
ça change considérablement la donne et
d'une certaine façon ça l'affaiblît et
du coup la tentation du passage en force
en l'occurrence ont petit à petit
succombé quand on est fort mais le
passage en force quand on est faible et
l'analyse politique quand même qu'on
peut faire c'est que emmanuel macron
n'est pas aussi fort que cela et qu'il
est même assez faible en cette rentrée
politique c'est extrêmement risqué et
puis on a tellement vrai il ya la
question des poids lourds de sa majorité
qui sont pas forcément aligner donc ça
peut aussi légèrement craqué quoi c'est
ça il ya les poids lourds et ya la
majorité les poids lourds c'est qui
c'est françois bayrou yaël brawn piles
et des pieds donc la présidente de
l'assemblée nationale
ils sont pas complètement chaud
bouillant pour cette déjeuner à matignon
il ya eu il ya eu le petit déjeuner de
la majorité
cette semaine effectivement au cours
duquel les choses ont été dites et les
principaux ténors de la majorité dont il
ya veste et craig il y avait à nice l'as
guérini avait yaël boon privé brunch iv
et françois bayrou ont émis des doutes
non pas sur la réforme elle-même et sur
la façon de la faire passer donc ça
c'est les ténors de la majorité et puis
après il ya la majorité la majorité je
vous rappelle qu'elle est relative à
l'assemblée nationale et qu'elle est
moins dociles que celle du premier
quinquennat j'ai vu quelqu'un du
gouvernement cette semaine qui me disait
le groupe n'a plus du tout envie d'être
considérés comme des députés qui sont
godillots et qui sont le doigt sur la
couture du pantalon au contraire ce
n'est plus un groupe bbc un groupe ados
et les ados c'est fait pour embêter les
parents la rue dans les brancards voilà
parce qu'ils savent aussi que emmanuel
macron ne sera pas réélu donc ils ont
aussi leur place leur place propre à se
faire et puis ils se disent aussi si
jamais emmanuel macron macron est obligé
de dissoudre durant le quinquennat ben
moi député la république en marche il va
falloir que j'explique à mes électeurs
que j'ai fait voter que j'ai fait passer
la réforme des retraites via un
amendement du projet de loi de la
sécurité sociale donc ça va pas être
simple donc tous ces éléments je ne
serai pas réélu s'il dit voilà c'est ça
et possiblement soit j'ai piscine soit
je vois là mais donc donc tout ça c'est
ça rend cette cette réforme par voie
d'amendement extrêmement difficile et il
ya effectivement on a commencé à
l'évoquer là la réponse des partenaires
sociaux vous propose d'écouter celles du
président du medef geoffroy roux de
bézieux
c'est une vision politique c'est tout
pour un public c'est au président de la
république et au gouvernement de prendre
ses responsabilités il ya une
configuration parlement qui est assez
particulière donc c'est décidé vous vous
dites ça ça vaut la peine de prendre le
risque éventuellement de tissus et de
l'éthique à laquelle au final c'est au
présent de répondre moi ce que je dis
simplement c'est qu'il faut faire cette
réforme parce que sinon le corps l'a dit
très clairement on a un problème pour la
retraite dans trois quatre cinq six ans
le corps le conseil d'orientation des
retraites évidemment jean sébastien
ferjou il n'est pas tout à fait d'accord
avec ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
lui dit il faut quand même aller vite
sur cette réforme ni trois quatre cinq
six ans il y avait trois d'urgence à six
mois il y en a une à court terme quand
même oui bien sûr mais qu'est ce qu'on
veut mettre dans cette réforme des
retraites parce que justement on il ya
eu tellement de consultation si on est
dans l' inverse du sprint des éthiciens
téléversement et combien ça a coûté à ce
que les consultations de jean paul
delevoye qui consulte tout le pays
pendant deux ans enfin à un moment c'est
pour ça je vous disais faire toujours
des français la variable d'ajustement je
ne conteste pas le fait que la
démographie française impose de toutes
façons de d'envisager une réforme des
retraites il ya bien des manières de le
faire et finalement dans les plus
simplement s'inscrire dans ce qui a déjà
été fait un allongement de la durée des
cotisations parce que dès que vous
rentrer dans les détails dès que vous
rentrez dans le système par points en
réalité ces cases inapplicable en france
tellement c'est un maquis de régimes de
retraite différents il est quasi
impossible aussi de trouver des règles
satisfaisante en matière de pénibilité
parce que l'idée séduisante mais dans la
réalité là encore le diable est dans les
détails et donc voilà il y avait une
voix qui était très simple qui n'a pas
été choisi par par le gouvernement bons
coups il ya un enjeu mais encore une
fois ça n'est pas les équilibres de
système des retraites que vise emmanuel
macron il vise les marges budgétaires
parce qu'on a beaucoup dépensé ailleurs
mais avant de beaucoup dépensé ailleurs
bien sûr qu'il faut un bouclier
tarifaire pour aider les français les
plus défavorisés
mais peut-être pourrions-nous faire des
bilans de ce que nous avons fait aussi
parce que quand je vous dis que l'état
lui ne se remet jamais en question sur
la location de ses finances ça mérite de
vrais débats au parlement un dernier mot
sur ce premier chapitre de notre débat
après on file aux journées
parlementaires aient l'air à biarritz
mathieu sous pierre sueur sur peut-être
la dimension européenne le regard de
l'europe sur une réforme attendue ça
peut jouer aussi alors effectivement à
la limite c'est le seul argument quand
on est dans un cadre européen comme le
nôtre aujourd'hui et qu'on est
effectivement un pays qui a le système
de retraite le plus favorable et qu'on a
un certain nombre d'efforts à faire
collectivement dans les années à venir
on peut vouloir donner des gages aux
partenaires européens il n'empêche que
je ne suis pas convaincu que olaf scholz
dans la période est pour préoccupation
principale d'appeler emmanuel macron
tous les jours pour lui demander de
réformer son système de commissions
bruxelles et de retraite et tout ça est
d'autant plus glissant que on est quand
même du coup sûr une retraite on sait
pas exactement ce sur quoi on va
atterrir mais on voit bien qu'on est
quand même sur une réforme qui est très
édulcoré par rapport au projet initial
que rappeler l'éthicien y compris même
par rapport au projet initialement
vendus avant le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle était la
retraite à 65 ans on discute pape il ya
eu un entre deux tours un peu compliqué
donc déjà emmanuel macron a mis de l'eau
dans son vin et la difficulté vient du
fait que quand même on est effectivement
sur un projet de réforme qui est très
largement rejetée par l'opinion donc le
président est affaibli et on sait que
l'opinion en face et quand même très
hostile à cette réforme ça veut pas dire
que l'opinion ne sait pas que
majoritairement hommage et moi j'ai
appris que quelqu'un de françois sur
sallanches et 64 ans par exemple est un
acte ça ne dérange pas du tout et bien
sûr que
je me suis quand même heureux le rejet
est très majoritaire les enquêtes
d'opinion qui existe depuis l'élection
présidentielle notamment fait état d'à
peu près une proportion des deux tiers
de français qui sont hostiles à la
réforme avec évidemment de grandes
variations en fonction de l'âge et au
delà ça y est du musée au cerveau une
question du sens sur le travail fin et
cette question là c'est un elle fait
partie du malaise démocratique donc
balayer tout ça dans un amendement en
passant je pensais vraiment prendre un
risque politique viendra leur travail
c'est le troisième chapitre en parlera
delà de la gauche et de la gauche des
allocs citation de fabien roussel mais
d'abord les journées parlementaires
aient l'air comme promis au fil à à
biarritz on y retrouve en duplex jérôme
rhabiller bonjour jérôme quelle chance
d'être à biarritz comment les les élèves
vont ils se se positionner justement
pour dans ce rôle d'opposant au
président la république
ils ont deux jours ici un de débats des
changes pour pas tenter d'accorder leurs
violons sur les grands textes
parlementaires de cette rentrée dont
ceux que vous avez évoquées à l'instant
dlr qui était affaiblie par les
résultats de la présidentielle et qui
sont pourtant au coeur de toutes les
attentions de toutes les discussions le
gouvernement a dit qu'ils voulaient
changer de méthode il a donc convié les
parlementaires à bercy hier pour
échanger sur le budget et bien jean
françois husson c'est un des sénateurs
qui étaient présents écoutez le et il
nous raconte le changement de ton c'est
une il ya une rupture c'est le président
et le gouvernement est devenu descriptif
puisque c'était très verticale pendant
le quinquennat précédent aujourd'hui
nécessité fait loi il ya un affichage
d'une volonté de faire autrement c'est
ni une instance de législation ni une
instance d'évangélisation a dit gabriela
talent et moi j'ai dit c'est encore
moins une instance de caporalisation
ces premières discussions jérôme elles
ont déjà un effet sur les parlementaires
aient l'air
n'ont pas vraiment thomas elles font
plutôt sourire voire un peu rire jaune
tout comme les pistes lancées par le
gouvernement comme par exemple de mettre
dans le projet de loi de finances les
droits de succession ou la réforme des
retraites que vous venez d'évoquer un
des thèmes très cher aux républicains
qui pourraient avoir du mal à ne pas
aller voter je n'ai jamais été autant
draguer nous a confié un parlementaire
sur le ton de la blague le problème pour
le gouvernement c'est qu'en face d'eux
une partie de l air et insensible à ses
avances écouter eric ciotti à ce sujet
il drague mais va se prendre un vent le
gouvernement voilà
nous sommes dans une opposition claire
moi j'ai été élu dans l'opposition les
électeurs qui ont voté pour moi à nice
comme ceux qui ont voté pour mes
collègues du groupe et ils nous ont
demandé d'être dans l'opposition et on
ne trahit pas mais sachons ne trahis pas
une confiance
un nom un non catégorique un d'eric
ciotti mais quand on interroge d'autres
parlementaires bas difficile pour eux de
voter contre ce qu'ils ont portées
depuis longtemps puis une troisième
catégorie chez les élèves écoutez bruno
retailleau qui rappelle que c'est le
gouvernement qui a besoin des
parlementaires les républicains et il
compte bien s'en servir pour faire
avancer des idées nous on votera ce que
nous votons d'habitude on votera
conformément à ce que nous avons
toujours fait je vais vous faire
remarquer que cet été sur beaucoup de
textes c'est pas nous qui avons voté les
textes la majorité macro nian c'est
plutôt eux qui ont voté notre texte
regarder le texte sanitaires il était
totalement remaniée on voulait nous
imposer à nouveau le pass sanitaires on
n'en a pas voulu on a remanié où l'art
est écrit et il a été voté
bruno retailleau eric ciotti qui sont
pas sur la même ligne on va rappeler
pour conclure jérôme que la campagne
pour la présidence de l air est lancé
ben c'est toute la difficulté actuelle
des républicains officiellement ils
doivent parler d'une seule voix mais
comme une campagne interne eric ciotti
aurélien pradié bruno retailleau bas on
n'entend qu'eux mêmes des voix
dissonantes parce qu'il faut bien se
différencier un bas preuve que comme
souvent on a beau être dans la même
famille bas il peut quand même d'avoir
une compétition merci jérôme les ombres
habillé en direct de biarritz pour ces
journées parlementaires et les airs
nathalie morice argent évidemment le
débat que qu'on avait un instant sur le
vote du budget comment s'opposer sans
forcément faire tomber le jour le
gouvernement c'est un peu la ligne de
crête elle est ressassé la ligne de
crête et l'air mais c'est même plus que
ça j'allais dire parce que ce projet de
loi de finance donc c'est toujours un
moment important parce que c'est avec le
projet de loi de finances qu'on
détermine si on est pour ou contre dans
la majorité c'est un moment important
puisque ça va arriver en pleine campagne
électorale votre journaliste l'a dit
pour la présidence et l'air mais ça va
tout changer et c'est loin d'être
anecdotique
là on a vu dans les sujets que vous avez
diffusé que on était quasiment sur une
compétition entre le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale l'assemblée
nationale qui est très très contre et
qui ne veut absolument pas donner le
point
à la majorité enfin à l'exécutif et de
l'autre côté les sénateurs qui eux sont
plus j'allais dire rond et plus sur le
fond des choses traditionnellement et
qui effectivement sont plus oui tout en
étendant magicien on parle même plus
constructif peu plus constructif donc et
c'est exactement ce qui va se passer au
sein de l une par les deux lignes de
crête sais mais c'est la ligne j'allais
dire de démarcation il va y avoir entre
les députés et les sénateurs et entre
bruno retailleau et eric ciotti mais
alors ça est ce que ça veut dire jean
sébastien sait le faire je me tourne
vers vous et se lassent la stratégie de
l air vis-à-vis de l'exécutif du pouvoir
des mails macron va être forcément
différente de celle du premier
quinquennat ou pas après vous ça va
dépendre du résultat des élections
effectivement je suis assez d'accord
vous aurez une sensibilité qui est plus
au sénat une sensibilité capucins de
l'ess de l'assemblée nationale mais je
crois pas que ça joue tellement sur le
côté macro compatibles parce que gérard
larcher s'est toujours montré très dur
sur sur emmanuel macron et à bloquer
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de réformes
comme la réforme des institutions
mais là où il ya une véritable
différence de sensibilité entre eric
ciotti et bruno retailleau c'est
probablement par rapport à l'idée qu'ils
se font de la stratégie pour que la
droite puisse revenir au pouvoir faute
il une droite qui soit combative très
combative en assumant d'être clivante ou
faut-il une droite qui essaye d'être
plus pas forcément plus rassembleuse
d'ailleurs parce que justement tout
l'enjeu du débat en matière d'efficacité
là mais en tout cas un peu plus modéré
sur la manière d'exprimer les choses et
ne se séparant pas du centre droit et
ces deux stratégies là effectivement
elles peuvent avoir un impact sur la
manière dont l air se fasse positionner
vis-à-vis du gouvernement mais ça n'est
pas le sujet premier leur sujet premier
c'est comment revenir au pouvoir en 2027
et est ce que c'est en recréant une
droite qui assumerait peut-être un peu
plus d'ailleurs une forme d'union
d'union de potentiel des droites au
moins au niveau des électorats ou une
droite qui dit bah finalement une partie
de la droite qui est parti dans
l'électorat face de notre électorat que
les partis chez emmanuel macron ramenons
le à nous et pour le ramener à nous il
ne faut pas nous montrer trop clivant
alors que sur le fond la ligne politique
elle est relativement similaire eric
ciotti et bono sur les fonts ça n'est
pas très très différent politiquement
alors justement il ya un troisième homme
c'est aurélien pradié il a officialisé
pas une surprise mais sa candidature à
la présidence et leers et au début de
cette semaine le député du lot qui
assume une ligne différente de celle de
l'histoire récente de son parti écouter
vous n'avez pas l'impression d'être il
faut qu'on change un truc ça fait dix
ans qu'on perd les élections on a fini
les présidentielles à moins de 5% enfin
qui est le le dingue qui considéraient
qu'il ne faut rien changer par les fous
aujourd'hui sont pas ceux qui veulent
changer les choses et poussant ceux qui
nous veulent ne rien changer la mathieu
ce qu'ils avaient dit que les heller ils
sont un peu perdus en ce moment est ce
que ça peut être une chance pour un
aurélien pradié quand même a priori
minoritaires aujourd'hui oui on va voir
enfin effectivement on disait que la
rentrée du président de la république
hâtif était compliquée la rentrée dlr
est encore plus compliqué c'est tout le
paradoxe de leers à l'opinion française
continue de se droitiser mais la droite
française est elle même très affaibli
mais pour une raison très simple c'est
tout l'équilibré instable en fait du
parti les républicains ils se sont fait
piquer leurs programmes à la
présidentielle ils se sont fait piquer
leurs électeurs ils se sont fait piquer
leurs parrains symbolique qu'elle
nicolas sarkozy et ils se sont fait
piquer leurs héritiers putatifs que sont
edouard philippe bruno le maire et
gérald à gérald darmanin pour la suite
donc c'est vrai que c'est dur est fait
beaucoup ça fait beaucoup et un congrès
et un congrès ça sert à quelque chose
pour un parti politique ça sert à
trancher une ligne politique à clarifier
une ligne politique et à se désigner un
leader qui normalement et les leaders
non seulement pour diriger le parti mais
pour le mener à la victoire électorale
aux prochaines échéances or là
précisément on va avoir un congrès qui
ne va pas véritablement nous permettre
leur permettre de trancher une question
de ligne politique à ce stade en tout
cas les deux favoris que sont
précisément bruno retailleau et eric
ciotti sont sur la même ligne il ya
peut-être des style un peu différent il
ya le sud de la france et puis la vendée
mais fondamentalement c'est quand même
la même ligne politique en matière
économique sociale fiscale et régalienne
donc il n'ya pas de vraie dis donc ça va
se jouer sur le ya pas de ré différence
alors notamment sur la personne que
trancher une ligne politique avoir un
débat entre deux orientations politiques
comme cela s'est toujours passé dans les
parties parce que les partis ne sont
jamais univoque uniforme c'est très
intéressant mais là on n'aura pas ça et
encore une fois celui qui sortira du
chapeau de toute façon ne sera à priori
pas le candidat du parti à l'élection
prés à la prochaine élection
présidentielle donc reste à voir quelle
efficacité ça sera elle de voir fini pas
je ne prends pas les paris à ce stade
mais il ya aussi une question il faut
les hôtes et elle est importante
nathalie morice avait question de de
ceux qui votent non comment ça marche et
l'importance des cotisations à jour on
va dire ça comme ça c'est ça donc on
fait que ce sont les adhérents qui qui
qui vont voter
pour reprendre un peu le film il y avait
cent cinquante mille à peu près
adhérents les républicains qui ont donc
voté pour la primaire qui a désigné
valérie précresse sur ces 140 mille cent
cinquante mille il en reste à peu près
50 minutes donc il y en a deux tiers qui
sont partis dans la nature pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont été déçus que leur
parti ne fasse que 4,8 pour cent au
premier tour de la dernière
présidentielle donc tout l'enjeu pour
les candidats qui sont favoris en
l'occurrence bruno retailleau eric
ciotti c'est d'avoir le plus d'adhérents
qui sont quasiment sûrs de voter pour
eux et là si on regarde la physionomie
dlr vous avez deux grosses fédérations
celle de l'île de france et celle des
alpes-maritimes celle des alpes
maritimes est acquise à eric ciotti
celle d'ile-de-france a beaucoup fondu
mais elle était acquise à valérie
pécresse donc tout le travail qui est à
faire pour bruno retailleau c'est de
s'affilier un certain nombre de barons
locaux partout dans les régions pour que
les barons locaux fassent des cartes
pardonnez moi cette expression mais
c'est comme ça que ça veut dire pour qui
est de plus en plus les deux plus
possible d'adhésion à 30 euros je
rappelle qu'il ya quand même quelque
chose qui est assez drôle si elle est l
air avec même carte bleue vous pouvez
avoir quatre adhésions se quatre
adhésions c'est à dire que vous vous
payez avec votre carte bleue thomas et
vous fait adhérer bas quatre mails
différent celui de vos enfants votre
cousin du pas de calais tél donc c'est
quand même c'est très mafieux comme
comportement c'est vraiment le sait si
l'effort mafieux mais non bâchés pardon
mais lors du défi exactement ce qui
s'est enfin c'est un manque de
transparence et
c'est pas forcément on comment dire
méchant nomades en demandant dans ma
bouche mais c'est le mode des
fonctionnements jours mais des partis
traditionnels qui fonctionne comme ça
oui jean-sébastien faire le coach c'est
d'accord effectivement on va d ailleurs
je sais de 10 qui sait faire des cartes
que l'expression employée mais il ya une
autre clé du scrutin quand même qui est
l'attitude de laurent wauquiez puisque
les uns et les autres se positionne par
rapport à laurent wauquiez eric ciotti a
dit très clairement qu'il pensait que
laurent wauquiez avait vocation à être
le candidat en 2027 et bruno retailleau
l'a dit - clairement mais là quand même
suggéré est donc la clé une des clef
puisque laurent wauquiez déjà est à la
tête d'une région on a vu que c'était là
où les députés où il ya beaucoup de
cartes et là où les députés aient l'air
en france ont fait globalement les
meilleurs scores et donc laurent
wauquiez lui a priori va soutenir eric
ciotti en tout cas c'est ce qui se dit à
l'heure actuelle peut-être on
assisterons nous à quelque chose de
l'ordre de ski c'était avec passé avec
michel barnier vous savez où tout le
monde mais en tout cas l'échelle barnier
lui disait laurent wauquiez je suis
candidat en sous-main laurent wauquiez
finalement on n'a jamais vu le soutien
public à arriver parce que la campagne
de michel barnier ne prenait pas je
pense que l'équipe de laurent wauquiez
plus déterminés à soutenir eric ciotti
donc effectivement ça va être un vrai
enjeu pour la droite parce que c'est
cette question de 2027 et c'est toute la
difficulté c'est que la logique en
réalité de la vème république c'est que
si vous êtes un parti d'opposition votre
chef ray vocation à être le prochain
préfet un candidat à la présidence de la
république on a fini par perdre sa de
vue il faut quand même du temps quand
vous voulez imposer une nouvelle matrice
idéologique et quand vous voulez
retrouver justement un électorat que
vous avez pu perdre il vous faut du
temps ça ne se joue pas dans un sprint
pour le coup dans les 18 derniers mois
en misant tout sur la personnalité aller
en termine à l'instant offre une
petrobras of de laurent wauquiez s'il
n'y va pas lui en 2027 ce sera au
deuxième tour mélenchon contre marine le
pen ça c'est une petite phrase qui
tourne en ce moment et vous pouvez même
la trouver dans la presse us chose en
rebond des chiffres que donne et
nathalie les 130 mille ou cent cinquante
mille adhérents mobilisés pour la
primaire est aujourd'hui réduit à 50
milles on enterre beaucoup eric zemmour
en cette rentrée on considère qu il est
passé totalement à côté de la
présidentielle il est quand même un des
quatre candidats à l'élection
présidentielle à s'être fait rembourser
ses dépenses de campagne loin devant
valérie pécresse est aujourd'hui son
mouvement affiche 130 mille adhérents
dont la moitié qui ont voté 30000
voter pour des élections je croyais que
c'était la moitié ou en tout cas 130
mille adhérents dont 30 minutes je me
trompais qui ont quand même voté pour
les ponts pour la gouvernance du parti
alors comparé encore une fois à ce que
sont les chiffres du parti les
républicains héritier du parti du
général de gaulle ça fait quand même
froid dans l'année je reprends la main
en termine avec la nuque ou la du ps qui
se déchirent autour de la valeur travail
tam traduit vous pouvez nous nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau bonjour
une rentrée évidemment
perturbé par les propos de fabien
roussel c'était le week-end dernier et
oui à la fête de l'huma ses concerts les
pieds dans la boue est désormais son
pavé jeté dans la mare par le secrétaire
national du parti communiste 1 il fait
une rentrée en fanfare fabien roussel
avec ses propos qui ont été commentés
toute la semaine dans les cas il a
opposé je le rappelle la gauche du
travail à la gauche des allocations et
des minima sociaux et hier dans une
tribune au monde et persiste et signe un
regard des j'assume défendre le parti du
travail dit il le chômage tu il bluesy
des vies il fait basculer des familles
entières dans la pauvreté est interrogé
hier sur france info fabien roussel
assume les divergences dans la grande
union de la gauche et jusque deux lignes
sont pas écoutés il ya ceux qui
défendent le droit à la paresse il ya
ceux qui défendent l'idée de mettre le
rsa à 1000 euros eh bien je défends moi
l'idée que nous devons garantir nous
devons nous projeter dans une société
qui garantisse à tous un vrai emploi une
formation les moyens financiers de le
mettre en place bref il a donc remis une
pièce dans la machine et susciter un peu
plus d'agacement au sein de la nuit pour
certains jugent ces propos
actionnaire et s'est notamment attiré
les foudres de la france insoumise mais
aussi des écologistes écoutez bien
justement sandrine rousseau ce matin je
vous dis qu'on a un droit à la paresse
je vous dis qu'on a un droit à la
transition des métiers c'est à dire que
quand on a un métier dans une industrie
polluante et bien on a le droit a changé
on a droit aussi de faire des pauses
dans sa vie et surtout il nous faut
retrouver du temps le sens du partage et
la semaine de quatre jours que là on est
pas du tout là dedans mais dans la
valeur travail mais la valeur travail
pardon mais c'est quand même une valeur
de droite
rousseau et roussel s'est pas exactement
la même vision de la gauche en revanche
ce qu'ils ont en commun c'est le goût
des sorties médiatiques louis l'un et
l'autre assume faire le buzz ils se sont
brillamment opposé 1 ces derniers jours
sur des histoires de barbecue et de
genre des grillades la viande est bien
c'est d'ailleurs le sujet qui avait
choisi fabien roussel comme marque de
fabrique pendant la campagne
présidentielle
la bonne viande le bon fromage le bon
vin comme slogan pour se démarquer de la
gauche quinoa cet ancien journaliste
c'est très bien comment faire parler de
lui cette fois s'il quitte donc un peu
plus en empruntant une partie du
vocabulaire aujourd'hui associé à la
droite c'est à dire la valeur travail
l'assimilation des allocations à
l'assistanat bref ils trient ans
ghislain c'est-à-dire qu'ils récupèrent
les mots de l'adversaire pour gagner de
nouveaux électeurs là ils cherchent les
classes populaires et il n'est pas seul
sur cette stratégie la gauche et oui dès
la semaine dernière fabien roussel a dit
dans son discours partagé les vues de
françois ruffin dans alternatives
économiques rufin qui fait souvent
cavalier seul à elle est fier a donc
déclaré la gauche doit redevenir le
parti de l'égalité de la fierté au
travail et depuis lui aussi a fait son
explication de deck de textes 1 dans son
blog sur mediapart
il explique en gros que fabien roussel
et lui sont d'accord sur le diagnostic
mais pas sur les solutions il estime que
fabien roussel agit comme un chef
marketing et qui le dit avec eux c'est
sortir ce sont ses mots lui appelle au
contraire à l'union pour ne pas laisser
au rassemblement national je cite encore
nos régions industrielles nos coins de
campagne n'ont pas grignoter mais avaler
à vitesse grand v et puis l'union de la
gauche on peut le rappeler aussi bien le
besoin d'accorder ses violons pour
parler d'une même voix sur les grandes
réformes qui s'annoncent notamment
celles de l'assurance chômage merci pour
toutes ces explications
jean sébastien ferjou je commence avec
vous peut-être sur le fond sur cette
justement cette valeur travail vous
commencez à l'évoquer tout à l'heure et
le sens du travail oui le sens et si
l'on met derrière ça c'est vrai derrière
ça il ya l'enjeu de parler aussi à un
électorat populaire qui s'est détourné
de la gauche depuis des années bien sûr
mais quand on entend sandrine rousseau
enfin je ne sais pas ça la luz donc tant
mieux quand on pose cette femme et
universitaires etc enfin le stakhanov ne
crois pas que c'était le héros de
l'union des républiques socialistes
capitaliste me semble quand même que le
travail on a oublié aussi mais ça semble
rosso s'en fiche puisque la réalité ne
l'intéresse pas que par exemple
gorbatchev vous savez encore gabat chose
quand il a été nommé secrétaire général
du parti communiste le kgb faisait des
descentes en russie dans les cinémas etc
pour aller chercher les gens qui ne
travaillait pas justement parce qu'il
voulait faire remonter l'économie
soviétique de toute façon c'est un
argumentaire mekyna mais historiquement
politiquement idéologiquement aucun sens
maintenant oui bien sûr que la question
posée par fabien roussel ou par françois
ruffin qui en substance dans le vif
qu'il sort cette semaine déploie
exactement le même argumentaire que
fabien roussel sauf qu'il le dit de
manière plus détournés et avec plus
d'égards vis-à-vis de jean luc mélenchon
mais oui bien sûr la question est celle
des catégories populaires parce que le
travail a un sens pour les catégories
populaires et la question de
l'assistanat elle est souvent à vrai
dire poser justement par des gens dit
catégories populaires ou moyenne ont
regardé les gilet jaune s'était pas il
n'était pas milliardaires nicad supens
sur les ronds-points et bien souvent ils
vous et nous sommes excédés par le fait
que à côté de chez nous il ya des gens
qui ne travaillent pas et qui gagnent
parfois plus que nous par le biais des
allocations donc oui ce sont deux
stratégies politiques totalement
opposées mais on voit bien qu'on ait une
gauche qui de toute façon a quitté le
champ du réel et qui est dans sa volonté
de détruire ce qui a fait les
fondamentaux de la civilisation des
démocrates libres vous dites que la
gauche a quitté le champ du réel c'est
une opinion la gauche
cette gauche la gauche sandrine rosso
oui d'accord mais on peut aussi mathieu
soutien sans faille nous sommes
peut-être qu'elle n'a pas tout à fait
tort on est quand même dans un rapport
au travail qui est en train de changer
la l'épidémie elle a bouleversé notre
rapport au travail la maison cocon dans
laquelle on se on se réfugie peut-être
que c'est assez français laquelle
s'adresse aussi à l'or sur la forme
effectivement tout ceci démontre que
sandrine rousseau n'a pas le monopole du
buzz et quand même ça m'amène à
commenter le fait que nous commentons
tous collectivement depuis déjà un
certain nombre de jours une déclaration
pardon mais d'un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle qui à la fin a fait 2 %
et par ailleurs d'une candidate battue à
la primaire d'europe écologie les verts
donc on est tous en train de se
positionner tout le débat politique se
structure autour d'une déclaration de
fabien roussel et puis d'un rebond de
sandrine rousseau et si encore lu mais
voilà ce que sur le fond mais alors
c'est pas seulement une querelle de
personnes fait une liste aussi alors sur
le fond c'est intéressant il ya un vrai
débat de fond sur quelle est la place du
travail dans nos sociétés aujourd'hui
pour autant je trouve que la polémique a
un côté un peu lunaire il y a un droit
au repos je sais pas s'il faut l'appeler
droit à la paresse mais évidemment un
droit au repos il est inscrit dans la
loi et il ya même un droit au travail
qui lui même est inscrit dans la
constitution
donc tout le monde a envie est de
travailler et de se reposer donc fait
c'est un peu artificielle d'opposer l'un
et l'autre je trouve ça tout à fait
artificielle et si on est rigoureux je
ne dirais pas du tout que rufin et
russel même combat ils ne disent pas la
même chose qu'ils aient pour partie la
même visée ou en tout cas la même
préoccupation de re capter les votes des
catégories populaires c'est réel et
c'est un vrai débat puisque la gauche
les a perdus d'accord mais ils ne disent
pas la même chose françois ruffin dit
valorisation du travail la gauche loi
rqap t en fait la valeur travail fabien
ocldi opposition de la france ou de la
gauche du travail et de la gauche ou de
la france des allocs il n'y a aucune
raison d'opposer le travail et les
allocs comme il n'y a aucune raison
d'opposer le travail et le repos et ce
quand on parle aux gens c'est
effectivement quand on assure que quand
vous lisez l'île de françois ruffin le
raisonnement il est sur le fond mais
encore y voir la valorisation du travail
c'est tout à fait de gauche et
d'ailleurs ça devrait être de gauche y
compris pour le leader du parti
communiste français parti des
travailleurs français mais opposer le
travail et la solidarité confondre la
solidarité mais l'assistanat c'est pas
ça c'est l'argumentaire que la fonction
soumise à reflets fabian
n'a jamais dit qu'il voulait supprimer
le rsa ou je me dis que la puce qui
n'auraient ajouté je universités la
réforme de l'assurance je termine
jean-sébastien quand on évoque la france
des allocs à coiffer ton implicitement
référence à une conviction de plus en
plus largement répandu dans l'opinion
selon laquelle il y aurait trop
d'assistanat dans notre pays c'est une
conviction partagée pas 75% des français
indépendamment d'ailleurs du taux de
chômage et qui y compris majoritaire à
gauche donc il y a une dimension
évidemment tactique est avant tout
tactique nonchalance klaus allofs de le
délit d objection
la société du chômage c'est donc tout le
monde est d'accord avec est
particulièrement inquiète c'est que un
des arguments pour le revenu universel
pour le coup et benoît
bon malheureusement n'a jamais rien
compris au sujet m'enfin bref c'est que
quand vous mettez en place des
expériences de revenu universel les gens
reviennent au travail précise et ils ne
dépensent pas pour aller au casino fumer
des cigarettes ou s'acheter je sais pas
quoi ça leur permet plus facilement de
revenir vers le marché du travail
pourquoi parce que le travail donne aux
gens insensés en pâte pour tout le monde
va me sandrine rousseau croit que j'ai
pas l'impression son vrai nom soit le
travail quand elle dit des conneries à
la télé c'est son travail sens donc là
ça a l'air de donner un sens à sa vie
malgré tout ça n'est pas que pour elle
pour les autres aussi alors il ya aussi
je vais reprendre la main parce qu'il
nous reste 5 minutes dans ce débat
j'aurais quand même content qu'on parle
aussi un peu de dd du jeu on va dire des
personnalités politiques laetitia parce
que derrière tout ça et à la question
aussi de jean luc mélenchon de la
succession de jean luc mélenchon de la
popularité de jean luc mélenchon oui moi
je pense que dans ce débat artificiel ou
pas le grand perdant c'est jean luc
mélenchon et je vais vous le démontrer
alors déjà françois ruffin avait dit que
s'il fallait reprendre le drapeau en
2022 si jean-luc n'y allait pas ireb
agent lui qui est allé mais
rappelez-vous au premier tour et dit à
ses troupes fait mieux et puis ensuite
on a l'impression qu'ils remontent à
cheval avec la nuque avec ce succès de
communication aussi et puis succès
politique et puis finalement ils
repêchent et leur pêche par égocentrisme
et roussel a là un mon avis carrément
ringardisé déjà mélenchon a fait une
erreur stratégique c'est de ne pas
siéger à l'assemblée nationale et puis
ils bloquent jean luc mélenchon sur la
réalité politique il veut absolument
refaire le film quand il revient à la
fête de l'humanité alors que ça dès 6
ans qu'il n'était pas venu c'est pour
dire ceci
l'accès au 2e tour à l'élection
présidentielle
ensemble
voilà l'ensemble ça veut dire avec
fabien roussel refaire le film est-ce
que ça serve à quelque chose je ne crois
pas ce que les journalistes ont vu et
surtout ceux dont ils ont témoigné c'est
ce jeu du chat et de la souris entre
jean luc mélenchon et fabien roussel et
d'ailleurs il ya une séquence qui a été
diffusée par plusieurs télévisions le
moment où jean luc mélenchon repart et
une journaliste du de l'émission
quotidien lui tend le micro unis
demandent pourquoi vous n'avez pas
serrer la main fabien roussel regardez
ce qu'il répond là il ya au moins cent
mille personnes dans cette fête que j'ai
pas saluer mais si vous pensez que je
suis venu ici pour me disputer avec
quelqu'un en outre on paie 1 parce que
moi je suis sympa kong à cette ironie à
mon avis une erreur de communication
politique pourquoi parce que je suis
assez d'accord avec vous un jean
sébastien ferjou justement fabien
roussel fait tout le contraire et je lui
joue le parler vrai il va sur les
terrains les territoires et il parle
comme effectivement les militants de la
gauche alors bien sûr que depuis ce
week-end est partout mais au-delà de
cette occupation médiatique il faut
écouter ce qu'ils disent et propos sont
très clairement énoncée par exemple sur
sud radio
la gauche doit l'emporter et je souhaite
le jour blanc portions il va falloir
qu'on avait convaincu ses 28 millions de
français qui ne sont pas allés voter aux
élections législatives je sais que ça
fait pas plaisir à tout le monde pour la
réalité celle là il ya 26 millions de
français qui ne sont pas allés voter
qu'ils s'abstiennent et leur attention
pour moi là beaucoup de sens et je veux
leur parler voilà donc il vient un cap
au delà des mots et des postures et même
de la personnalité et même de la com de
fabien roussel il veut raccrocher à la
gauche au plein emploi ce n'était pas
idiot parce que le plein emploi ça a été
complètement préempté par emmanuel mâcon
qui en a fait un peu l'étendard de son
second quinquennat et finalement fabien
roussel a peut-être la meilleure réponse
à apporter au gilet jaune qui au delà
des écrans plats voulait certainement
retrouver leur dignité justement sur la
valeur et le sens du travail ou
rejoignez sur cette analyse nathalie
mort et pour l'instant ça tient cet
attelage delà de la nuque ou de la nuque
est ce parce qu'il n'y a pas d'échéance
électorale à court terme on peut dire ça
comme ça tous tellement peu non ça tient
pour ça c'était un accord électoral la
nouvelle enseigne par un accord sur le
fond je vous rappelle que dans l'accord
qui a été signé il avait justement mis
de côté tout ce qui
des départager qu'est-ce qui les
départageait c'était principalement le
positionnement par rapport à l'union
européenne or qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
dans deux ans c'est des élections
européennes donc cet accord qui est un
accord électoral tiendra bon gré mal gré
jusqu'en dominique 24 et en 2024 il y
aura plusieurs listes de gauche
présentait notamment une liste verte
enfin une liste écolo et une liste
communiste parce qu'ils ont
effectivement de
faire de conception complètement
différente du bus travail et je trouve
que ce qui est de l'europe mais le
laisse je rebondis donc effectivement
c'est tout cette polémique sur le
travail est assez passionnant parce
qu'on voit qu'il ya deux conceptions
totalement différente du monde du
travail du rapport au monde et c'est
beaucoup plus profond que ça ne me
paraît merci beaucoup merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce premier
débat je vous dis à bientôt dans ce sens
public